hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast exploring and preventing
cell culture contamination i'm susie
valdez of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at
www.thermofisher.com
so let's get started i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click the send button if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
mary kay bates a senior global cell
culture scientist at thermo fisher
scientific
for a complete biography on our
presenter please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
mary kay welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much susie it's great to
be here with lab roots today thanks to
everyone at lab roots and the whole team
at thermo fisher scientific for helping
to present
this event today i'm really excited to
be here
so part of my job with thermo fisher is
to kind of talk about cell culture
contamination
and how it affects lab equipment and
working in the lab
i have to confess that a big part of
putting this talk together is
thinking about don't do the things that
i did when i was in the lab for 20 years
in cancer research and gene therapy
research at a small biotech company so
a lot of the the underlying theme here
is gosh i wish i had thought more about
this when i was in the lab
so hopefully you will find this
information helpful
so let's go to an overview of the
presentation
i'm going to begin with talking about
what is cell culture contamination
including the types of contamination
and the extent of the problem so i think
it's important that we all begin
at the same place and so really
contamination is
anything that infects the culture or
makes it
impure so with a better understanding of
what is
what are the different types of cell
culture contamination then we can look
at
recommendations to reduce contamination
and then the second half of the talk
will be
looking more closely at different co2
incubator designs that
help to fight contamination in the
incubator
that's important because the cell
culture incubator is where your cells
spend most of their time so i would
argue that it's the most important lab
equipment
for for keeping yourself healthy and
then i'll finish up with some
conclusions
so let's get into talking about the
types of cell culture contamination and
we'll start with viruses
the smallest types of cell culture
contamination
we i think we're all thinking about
viruses a lot globally right now
so what do you do if you have a virus in
your cell culture
the thing about viruses is you can't see
them under a regular microscope and they
don't
cause a ph indicator change in your
growth medium
so you you may not know that you have a
virus in your culture
theoretically you could use antiviral
drugs to to limit
viruses growing in your cultures but
those drugs
can also be toxic to the host itself so
that's
generally not a good idea the good news
about viruses
is like the common cold or even like the
sars covid
ii virus that everyone's so
concerned about right now those viruses
tend to be self-limiting on an
individual basis
so with regard to viruses the major
concern is the potential risk to you
working with those cell cultures that
could be harboring a latent virus
that's a special concern if you're
working with human cells
so it's important with that in mind to
make sure that your
biosafety cabinet is properly balanced
and certified
so bacteria and fungi these are actually
my favorite types of contamination to
talk about
because they're ubiquitous in a lab
environment they're everywhere
they're in us they're on us they're in
the environment
and so they're the most common
contaminant in cell cultures
they're the damage that they do happens
because they grow so quickly so e coli
at their very best
can multiply once every 20 minutes that
compares to
your mammalian cells which multiply once
every 24 to 48 hours depending on the
cell type and how happy they are in
culture
this picture here i expect that pretty
much everybody on the call who's working
with cultured cells has seen something
like this when you pick up your flask or
your dish
and you see that your growth medium has
become cloudy
so that's an indicator of a bacterial or
a yeast
contamination happily growing in your
culture
if you see something that looks sort of
like a tumble tumbleweed that
bounces around the desert in those
western cowboy movies
at least that's how i think about molds
as you'll see they have
branches and they they kind of look like
a very large dust kitty
or a furry clump that's an indicator
that you have a mold contamination
so the the dangers to your cultured
cells here
is that um many of these species can
shift the ph they produce lactic lactic
acid as a byproduct of metabolism so
they make the culture medium very acidic
which makes the the conditions not good
for your cultured cells
and also because they grow so much
faster than your mammalian cells they're
going to take up all of the nutrients in
the growth medium
leaving nothing left for your cells so
your cells are going to become
very sick if that culture continues with
harboring bacteria and fungi
mycoplasmas these are the most serious
and widespread contaminant because
of their low detection rate that's why
it's microplasmas everywhere and also
because of their negative effects on
cells
mycoplasma has come from us there are
more than 100 different species of
microplasmas
some of which are human pathogens some
of which are human normal flora
microplasmas often also commonly come
from other cultures
maybe some cultures that you receive
from a colleague in a different lab
a lot of people are not aware that
mycoplasmas are technically bacteria
but they are much smaller than most
bacteria they can be as small as 0.2 or
0.1 micrometers in size
because they are so small you can't see
them under the microscope and they can
become
really really dense in your culture
without
visible signs they don't cause a ph
shift and you wouldn't see the
cloudiness of the growth medium
although they are technically bacteria
they do not have a cell wall
that makes them resistant or unaffected
by most antibiotics which are directed
against
the peptidoglycan in the bacterial cell
wall
so if you're using penicillin and
streptomycin in your growth medium that
does not protect you against mycoplasma
also because they're so small and they
don't have a cell wall
once in a while if you're using filter
sterilization for your growth media or
your reagents
uh once in a while mycoplasmas could
slip through those filters
mycoplasma's effects on the cells are
also
really a big impact so they can affect
the host cell's metabolism
the morphology i knew one guy who said
he could he didn't have a mycoplasma
contamination because his cells looked
fine
that's not true you can't necessarily
tell by looking at your cultures
if they have a mycoplasma contamination
so an early sign that you have a
mycoplasma contamination might be that
your cells
grow more slowly you might see them
clump
or you might not you might see that
instead of having to split your cells
three times per week maybe now you have
to split them twice a week or even once
a week
and you kind of start complaining to
people geez i don't know what's wrong
with myself they just kind of have
stopped growing
another key indicator is reduced
transfection efficiency so if your
transfection efficiency has gone down to
close to zero
that's a big that should be a big red
flag to you that you might have a
microplasmid contamination
microplasmas can alter the chromosomal
sequence
damage dna and provoke cytopathic
responses so
they're very serious problem in cell
culture
so if you can't see them under the
microscope and you don't see any ph
change the bacterial the growth medium
doesn't get cloudy like it would with
other bacteria
how can you detect them well the only
way you can see mycoplasmas is using a
dna dye
such as hoaxed or dappy so i'm going to
show you some images of detecting
microplasma using gibco's microflora
microplasma detection kit
in panel a these are hek293 cells
that are negative for mycoplasma this is
a fixed culture so the nuclei of the
cells
are glowing um blue for the from the
dappy stain of the dna of the cells
in panel b this is an hek293 cell
culture which is fixed and this is
positive for mycoplasma so you can see
the blue dots here in and around the
cells
that are glowing blue indicating the dna
in the microplasma
and panel c is is really the one i think
is the best these are unfixed
cells so the dna die doesn't enter the
cells so the cell nuclei do not light up
and you can clearly see
the blue dots throughout the culture
indicating a mycoplasma contamination
now there are a lot of elisa kits to
detect microplasmas
there are a lot of pcr kits to detect
microplasmas
none of those will detect every single
one of those more than 100 species
but it's still a good idea to you know
they're directed against the most common
species
but the best practice is to either use a
dna stain which will show you any
mycoplasma in the culture
or consider using two other methods to
give you a broader spectrum test of the
mycoplasma
another type of cell culture
contamination is cross contamination
with other cells
this happens when you're working with
two or more cultures at the same time
and you accidentally cross contaminate
the other
culture and one of those cell types
grows much faster and after a few
passages
all of your cultures are that faster
growing cell type
so some examples of this are hela cells
hela cells are just
such aggressive cells and they've
mutated so much
that they really grow very efficiently
in cell culture
and so if you accidentally contaminate
your
you know any cell type your ovarian
cancer with hela cells
after a few passages you will not have
any
ovarian cells left that will be only
hela cells
so in some fields years of work is based
on the wrong
cells so that's that's really concerning
and more and more journals are now
requiring proof of identity
uh in order to accept a manuscript for
publication
the only solution to preventing
and the spreading of these cells which
are misidentified
across the world is to use cell lines
that are confirmed by dna fingerprinting
so most cell banks will now offer
dna identified cell lines and so i would
recommend doing that
if you get cells from a colleague like
most of us have done or and continue to
do
please ask that colleague if they have
done a dna fingerprinting on those cells
to be sure
that they really are what your colleague
says they are
the last type of contamination i'll talk
about are volatile organic compounds and
this is another type
that i think a lot of us don't think
about very much so especially if you're
doing a lot of molecular biology
applications and you're using
phenol chloroform beta mercaptoethanol
isoemol alcohol and so on
or molecular biology applications or
organic chemistry applications in your
lab
those volatile chemicals dissolve really
easily in liquids especially cell
culture media
and then they can have negative effects
on your cultured cells
another thing that we don't think about
is how the cleaners and disinfectants
were using in the labs
affect the cultured cells so these would
include chlorine bleach
which has a very strong
[Music]
odor ammonia which is not used as much
anymore
floor wax is a good example if your
laboratory goes on holiday or
you know during things shut down during
the pandemic and the cleaning crews go
in and
clean and clean the floors and wax the
floors
um it's happened a number of times that
we get a call
that there must be something wrong with
the incubator because
the cells are dying and after doing a
little more detective work in an
investigation we find
that actually the custodial crew went in
during a break
and cleaned and waxed the floors and
fumes from those chemicals
have negatively affected the cells
so these vocs have been shown to
increase expression of heat shock
proteins that's an indicator of stress
other stress proteins that are not
characterized as heat shock proteins and
overall cytotoxicity so it is a concern
and something to be aware of if you're
doing
if you're using these chemicals in your
laboratory
so that's that's the kind of the list of
contaminants
um but is contamination really a big
deal i found this quote a few years back
from carolyn k lincoln and she says cell
culture contamination continues to be a
major problem at the basic research
bench
as well as for bioproduct manufacturers
contamination is what truly
endangers the use of cell cultures as
reliable reagents and tools
and as we start to use cells and cell
products more often for
biopharmaceutical applications for cell
therapy
it seems like every month there's a new
approved monoclonal antibody
cell culture and contamination is really
a big deal yes
i've given this talk all around the
world and
used to give people the opportunity to
respond to polling questions
using little remote clickers and
everybody could be anonymous
and when i ask people have you had a
contamination event in the past 12
months
87 percent had at least one
contamination event
in that previous year and most of them
had multiple contaminations
so yes contamination is a big deal
everybody
working with cell cultures has struggled
with contamination at some time
and it's something we have to talk about
because if we don't talk about it
then you know we're not addressing the
problem
so where does contamination come from
primarily
contamination comes from us from our
normal flora and our hands
our breasts on our hair
swabs of human skin this was a study
done by elizabeth grice a few years back
she found
10 000 microorganisms per square
centimeter
on everybody that they tested on average
contamination also comes comes from the
air
normal indoor air contains between 30
and 1000 microorganisms
per cubic meter that's a kind of a big
range so it depends on how clean you
keep the laboratory
and then also of course volatile organic
chemicals traveling in the air across
the laboratory
so microorganisms are all around us
and we have to be aware of that in order
to think about how to control
that risk of contamination
and as the use of cell culture increases
the risk
of contamination comes along with that
so here's some statistics if we want to
talk about the extent of the problem
up to 15 of u.s cell lines
stored in cell banks and also 23 percent
of research lab cultures
were found to be carrying mycoplasma in
a review
in 20 2002.
in europe the rates of microplasmas are
up to 40 percent
in japan as high as 80 percent it seems
that that rates are
inversely correlated with the amount of
testing so if you test for microplasma
you're aware that you have it and you
can control that problem before it
spreads before you share those cells
with a colleague
in a different laboratory or before you
spread them across your laboratory
but even biopharmaceutical cultures can
be contaminated so eight and a half
percent
of the tested biopharmacultures were
contaminated
based on a study in 2010
so what are the costs of all of this
contamination
for those of you who have battled a
contamination in your lab
you have an understanding of how much
time that takes you can't do
anything if your cells are contaminated
until you
solve that contamination or if they're
carrying mycoplasma until you determine
what is the source of that poor cell
growth or poor transfection efficiency
and then of course repeating all of
those experiments the cost of the
plastic wear and the growth media all
add up
over time there was a letter in nature
i think it was nature a few years back
where a
stem cell pi estimated that his lab had
spent
up to 100 thousand dollars fighting a
mycoplasma contamination
ultimately if you've published on
ovarian cancer and it turns out that
your cells were actually breast cancer
for example
that can affect your public your
credibility you might have to withdraw
or retract a publication or publish a
correction
in biopharmaceutical manufacturing if
you think about a contamination
of a monoclonal antibody that entire
production lot must be discarded it
can't be
used in a medical treatment
so i found a version of this graph a few
years back in ian freshney's textbook
culture of animal cells and i've decided
to make it my own
so this is my version taken from dr
freshney
so on the x-axis here we're showing time
over the course of one year 52 weeks
and i think about this in terms of my
own life and my own work in the lab in a
project and on the y-axis
i'm graphing the quality or the percent
of what it is i'm measuring
so let me tell you a little story so
it's the start of a new semester
and i've got a new project and i am so
excited because
we've got it all planned out and we've
got a really good game plan for the
experiments
and what to test and how to test it and
it's a great question
and i'm gonna get published in science
and i'm so excited and i'm doing
everything right so here you can see the
red line is graphing the quality of my
aseptic technique
i'm being really careful
and at the same time i'm going to graph
the quality of the lab environment
what's the level of contamination
floating around in the lab
so as i said it's the start of a new
semester and we've got a new
undergraduate working in the lab his
name is mike
and mike is really excited it's his
first laboratory job and so it's his job
to clean the lab maybe not so glamorous
but
it's it's important work and so he's
doing a great job and you can see
at the beginning here the the lab is
really clean there's a low amount of
circulating contamination
and then one day i'm working in the bsc
in the hood splitting myself and my
friend stephanie comes in
and stephanie starts to tell me about
this cute guy who has joined the
laboratory down the hall
and i start laughing and i accidentally
touch my pipette tip to the outside of
my
media bottle so i have a lapse in my
technique
but i realize i did that i discard that
pipette tip i go and i get a new sterile
tip
and my the quality of my technique goes
back to
pretty good nearly a hundred percent
and now it's midterms and mike has
skipped a few days of cleaning the lab
because he's got to study for
exams and so we see a dust and dirt
building up in the lab
but then mike does okay on his exams and
he comes back into the lab
and you know things are going okay
and time goes on now it's quite a few
weeks into my project
and i'm not getting the clear-cut
stunning results that i expected
i'm having to go back and troubleshoot
and figure out what's going wrong what
can i do differently and at the same
time
my pi has loaded another project on my
plate and
i'm stressed and i'm worried about time
and i'm starting to skip steps
you can see that i'm having more lapses
in my technique
at the same time mike has figured out
that cleaning the co2 incubator and
cleaning the centrifuge
and the water bath is not so glamorous
after all
and he's not doing quite as good of a
job and so there's more circulating
contamination in the laboratory
and these trends continue until suddenly
these two lines cross and that's where
you get a contamination
so i have a little talk with mike and
explain to him
how important it is to keep the lab
clean to do a good job because
everything we do depends on how the
cells grow
and i also have a little talk with
myself that skipping these steps is
actually not
saving me time because now i've got a
contamination
and i've got to do everything over
everything you know that
with those cells is questionable and so
the cycle begins again
so usually when i give this talk to a
live audience at this point people are
kind of giggling
and talking amongst themselves and maybe
you see yourself in this story as well
hopefully that kind of demonstrates how
contamination occurs
so with that in mind now we can look at
some recommendations to reduce
contamination
number one pay close attention to your
aseptic technique
do all of those things that you know
you're supposed to do
um wash your hands when you go into the
lab wear your lab coat
in the lab don't wear it outside the lab
a few years ago
i was in new york city working with some
some scientists there and
we went out for lunch and i was shocked
the number of people
wearing their lab coat out on the street
in new york city it is a really cool
status symbol
that you work in a lab and you wear a
lab coat but it's called a lab coat
for a reason so leave it in the
laboratory
wear gloves every time you touch your
incubator
touch it with only with gloves on and
things that you touch without gloves on
don't touch them with your gloves on if
you get a text while you're splitting
yourselves
try to avoid picking up your phone and
if you do
you know succumb to that temptation then
just switch out and put on fresh globs
work with only one cell type at once at
one time i used to be so excited
when i had several cell types that all
grew in the same dmem
plus additives and i was really proud of
myself actually i thought i was
being really efficient and being a
production line um
by you know splitting them all at the
same time that is a fabulous way to
cross-contaminate yourself
don't be like me don't do this work with
only one cell type at once
don't share reagents across cell types
even if they're exactly the same
growth media and additives alec bought
your complete media so that you can use
a different aliquot for each cell type
notes of all of your cell culture work
every time you touch those cells
write down what you did take a few extra
minutes when you're looking at the
confluence under the microscope
slow down and note what do the cells
look like
not just how confluent are they but are
the membranes nice and tight to the dish
you see any granules in the cytoplasm
that might be an early indicator of a
stress response
what did you do with the cells and if
you do get a contamination
write that down what did you see what
did you experience
what was the time that allows you to
pinpoint and isolate problems before
they spread
clean the lab clean the lab clean the
lab clean
clean the lab nothing is more important
other than your technique and cleaning
the laboratory
so you should clean and disinfect the
lab at least one time per month
including the corners where you have
those boxes of plastic where
piled up move those and get the dust
kitties out from
behind them clean under the equipment
everybody i think is pretty good about
cleaning the water bath but do you think
about the centrifuge
you clean and disinfect the centrifuge
buckets in the centrifuge rotor and
chamber
the microscope stage and eyepieces um
disinfect the calculator now and then
things like that
um the refrigerator and freezer let's
talk about that for a minute
fungi love damp cardboard
that's a nice source of a home and some
nutrients for fungi so
try to eliminate cardboard storage in
the lab use plastic instead
when you aliquot your media and date it
that allows you to keep track of how old
is that media and you can get rid of it
when it's kind of
gotten to be too old such that maybe the
additives aren't at their best anymore
you want to use
only precisely balanced growth media for
yourselves
consider contamination control mats i
have another confession here
in one of the labs i worked at the lab
manager installed these
sticky contamination control mats inside
and outside
the cell culture room door so that you
walk across and it pulls
you know pulls the dust and dirt off
your shoes and i kind of teased him i
thought it was kind of silly
but actually in retrospect it's a really
good idea because if
if you wear your street shoes in the
laboratory and then on
you know in north america where we're
having beautiful weather right now
you go out to lunch and then you wear
your street shoes back into the lab
that's a great way to bring
environmental contamination into the lab
i know in asia most of you have separate
laboratory shoes that you wear only in
the lab and that's a really good idea
when you're working with yourself please
don't use antibiotics
they are not going to protect you
against microplasmas and it's really
only going to mask
the problem it's really better to see
that culture that contamination in the
culture immediately because you're not
going to have
a pure contamination it's more likely
going to be
pseudomonas or reginosa mixed with
mycoplasma or staphylococcus aureus
and so if you use antibiotics that will
kill off
the pseudomonas and the staph but not
the mycoplasma so it's better to see
that
cloudiness of your growth medium
immediately and you can discard that
culture before that contamination
spreads
use only cell lines confirmed by dna
fingerprinting so you know that your
cells are truly what you think they are
consider using a quarantine incubator
when you get cells from a colleague you
can isolate
those cells in a separate incubator for
a few weeks until you've had time to
passage them
make sure they're healthy and run a
mycoplasma test
consider running a microplasma test
every month i know that's a lot to ask
it can be a lot of work some some
facilities
have a core lab that will run those
tests for you
but at least consider running a
microplasmid test quarterly
because if you routinely test that's
going to control the incidence
of your mycoplasma keep it from
spreading and
you'll you'll isolate that problem
before it becomes a big problem across
your lab
like one of my labs experienced
so let's look at the biosafety cabinet i
can't really quiz you because you're all
unable to speak but here's an example of
a bad work environment in the biosafety
cabinet
so what's wrong with this picture first
of all there is so much stuff
in this bsc that all of the vents in the
back are blocked
that prevents this safety cabinet from
doing its job
those vents have to be able to
filter the air um there are pipe headers
on both sides
so somebody's not working from clean to
dirty there are stacks of empty pipette
boxes
you know you have you should be working
from clean to dirty one side to the
other so that you're not
carrying old media across your cells
also the uv light is on and the sash is
still open
part way because of that tubing for the
vacuum pump
so that means that uv light is probably
escaping and putting
people's corneas of their eyes at risk
so what are some recommendations for
working in the bsc
number one avoid clutter take everything
out that you're not actually working
with
number two work a few inches or
centimeters inside that front grill
don't have your hands right over the
grill that's not helping you and it's
blocking the vents
use slow arm movements try to work
slowly in and out
not side to side proper aseptic
technique means that you
hold that lid of the dish or the bottle
in your hand
don't put it down and try to help cover
the opening
so that micro organisms are not falling
onto your cultures
and as i said work from clean to dirty
so if you're right-handed
keep the waist to your right hand so
that
you're not carrying that waste over your
cultures
i think it helps a little bit to
understand how does that bsc airflow
work
so that's what this picture shows you
can see that the hepa filtered clean air
is coming straight down the middle and
then it splits
um to go down into the front and the
back fence
um and so you can see it actually forms
a lateral
air curtain to help keep contamination
from crossing side to side so that's why
it's so important
to work from clean to dirty left to
right if you're right-handed
and then again keep those air vents
clean because
or you know available because that's
what is protecting you
and protecting yourselves from
contamination
if you're working with those motorized
pipe headaches or
make sure that you change those filters
regularly
maybe once a month and especially when
they get wet
keep a biohazard bag inside the bsc for
waste one of my laboratories that i
worked in people kept the biohazard
waste bag outside the bsc the problem
with that is that your hands are
constantly moving
inside and outside the hood workspace
and you're bringing contaminated lab air
in with you so keep the biohazard inside
the hood
and then empty it daily if you do have a
spill clean it immediately
and clean inside that whole bsc once per
month
inside the walls lift up that work
surface
hopefully you won't see a lot of pretty
colors under there because you've been
cleaning it regularly
otherwise that is a source of
contamination when you have dried media
under there
a bsc is very very clean but it's not
sterile so things can grow under the
work surface if they have nutrients
there
and then clean inside the glass as well
okay so for the rest of the talk we're
going to talk about the co2 incubator
this is my favorite
laboratory equipment because it's where
your cells grow
so what about the the co2 incubator
number
one to fight contamination change to
fresh
sterilized distilled water once each
week
if you just top it off you're just
putting fresh water on top of dirty
water so
dump out the old water and put in fresh
sterilized distilled water
once each week that will really help
control contamination in your incubator
and we recommend only sterilized
distilled water i know a lot of labs use
deionized water
but water that's deionized will pull
ions
from the stainless steel and from the
glass and over time
you can see corrosion and rust of the
stainless steel and the glass door gets
cloudy because it's corroded
clean the incubator at least once per
month you can use 70
ethanol and allow it to air dry don't
recommend a lot of stronger
disinfectants because they can cause
corrosion too
and we have some advice that we can
share with you if you sign up for an
email we can send you some
best practices there clean the doors and
the door handles anything that you touch
should be clean and disinfected
regularly
um room air vents blowing onto the
incubator it's actually really
surprising how many labs i go into now
that i know to look for this
and i look up at the ceiling and there's
an air duct
in the ceiling for the building air
handling system and it's blowing
directly onto the incubator
and those air ducts can harbor fungi the
fungi love that
damp dark air space and that blows it
directly on the incubator so if possible
you can talk to your facility manager
about redirecting that airflow
do not store anything on top of the
incubator i know this is a lot more
common in north america than in europe
and asia
i i'm guilty of this also i thought that
that horizontal space
was a really great place to store boxes
of gloves and test tubes
because as we know space on shelves in
the lab is pretty limiting so
um that's that was what i did and it
turns out it's a bad idea because that
can collect dust and dirt on top of the
incubator and then when you open the
incubator door
that dust and dirt blows into the
incubator so clean the top
as well and before by the same token
make sure the incubator is on a stand
not directly on the floor so that you
you're not sweeping dust and dirt from
the floor into the incubator
and when you do get a spill clean it
immediately
all right so for the rest of the talk
let's talk about how the incubator
can actually help you fight
contamination
so the co2 incubator that's where your
cells are living that's where they're
growing
everything depends on that incubator not
being contaminated and doing its job to
grow the cells properly
now all incubators are the same in one
way and that is that they have a door
and so when you open that door
contaminants can come inside the
incubator and the incubator's job is to
grow things
so whenever you open any incubator the
door the incubator interior
is at risk so one way to help is to use
an incubator that itself
will help prevent contamination growing
in the incubator
so let's talk about some technologies
that can help
the first i'll talk about is
antimicrobial copper it's
naturally antimicrobial this has been
known for thousands of years
the ancient greeks and the ancient
aztecs
used uh copper as a topical treatment
for
skin trauma so you know if you cut your
hand
or you got hurt in battle you could put
copper on there it would help prevent
infection
copper will actually kill not only
bacteria and fungi but also viruses
it even inactivates prions it's easy to
work with you don't need to use an
additional disinfectant so it saves you
time
it works 24 7 and it's actually safe for
cells because your cells
it's not airborne it only kills on
contact so your cells and culture dishes
are safe
this is a quote from a pi i talked with
a few years ago
he was so excited about his copper
incubators once they switched to copper
they just had no contamination
and the lab next door their stainless
steel incubators was still fighting
contamination
um and they didn't have to clean the
incubator as often
he felt the copper was really saving
them time and money
so how does copper work well a few years
back the u.s environmental protection
agency
tested more than 300 different alloys of
copper and they found that you have to
have at least
60 copper in order to have any
antimicrobial
antimicrobial activity so this is
a picture showing testing with different
alloys of copper
and testing um what is that
50 million uh methicillin-resistant
staphylococcus aureus so
mrsa bacteria that are antibiotic
resistant
and they found that on 99 to 100 copper
all of those bacteria were eliminated in
90 minutes it was probably even faster
but that was the first time point they
looked at and as you reduce the copper
content you can see that 80 percent
copper takes
much longer to kill all those bacteria
and as you go down to 55
copper it never kills all of them and
stainless steel had no effect
so only a 100 copper will give you
maximum
efficiency on copper now
copper is a naturally occurring element
and it reacts with everything and one of
the things that it reacts with is copper
as uh
oxygen and so copper develops a natural
tarnish or patina just like
good quality brass which is mostly
copper or good quality silver will do
so this test shows the effectiveness of
the tarnish the tarnish actually makes
the copper
more effective so here this group has
taken
the one centimeter squares of copper of
different alloys
and tested them with 50 million e coli
o157 h7 one
one version of e coli that causes food
poisoning and they found
that the 99 copper does have some effect
when tested over the course of an
hour but not that much more than 90
percent copper
and then they took these same squares of
copper and put them outdoors in new york
city for one year and let them develop
a really strong tarnish or patina they
looked blue and
black and green and then they
disinfected them and added the e coli
again
and look what happens when that copper
gets oxidized it's much more effective
so in the incubator the copper also is
going to get black and green
it's going to develop that kind of
tarnish that's not something to be
afraid of because tarnished copper is
much more effective
than bright copper
i'm going to talk about a few more
technologies to help fight
contamination in the incubator and the
next one is hepa filtration
and i'm going to talk about this because
like copper it's a common misconception
about how
hepa filters work hepa filters actually
do capture
all particles circulating in the air
regardless of their size
and this is confusing because hepa
filters are rated for their efficiency
of capturing 0.3 micrometer particles
and it's confusing because if you think
about gas line
air filters those disk filters on the
back of your incubator
that filter the incoming gases those are
also
0.3 micrometer but in that case it's
talking about the pore
size is 0.3 micrometer so it's not
capturing
smaller particles that's not true with a
hepa filter a hepa filter
is it's an efficiency rating for 0.3
micrometers and you can see on this
chart that what happens is the 0.3
micrometer particles
kind of fall between the different
physical processes
that are active in capturing those
particles
so smaller and part and larger particles
are actually captured with higher
efficiency in a hepa filter
so it's a good idea to put a hepa filter
in a co2 incubator but
different manufacturers have applied
this
with different varying efficiencies so
if i hold a hepa filter in my hand it's
not going to filter
the air in my room you need to have
forced air
through that hepa filter in order to
clean it it's not a passive system it's
an
active system so a good hepa filtration
system will filter the entire
incubator air volume every 60 seconds
providing iso class 5 clean room
conditions only 5 minutes after
a 30 second door opening
now some manufacturers will say yeah we
have hepa filters on our incubator we
have
five or seven hepa filters they're
actually calling that gas line air
filter a hepa filter and that's not true
a hepa filter is three-dimensional and
you should look for one that's actually
in the incubator chamber
protecting the air that your cells are
experiencing
if the hepa filter is in the electronics
compartment and you have to use
tools to change it that's probably not
the best design
okay i'm going to finish up talking
about on-demand
types of contamination control in the
incubator
and there's just a few technologies left
to talk about the first is dry heat
sterilization
and this can be confusing because years
ago the international pharmacopoeias
would
date a given time and temperature so you
had to have
160 degrees for two hours and that was
sterilization
or 140 degrees for two and a half hours
and that was sterilization
and so manufacturers would say okay
check mark we've got 160 degrees for two
hours
we provide sterilization and it turned
out that some areas of those sterilizers
or incubators
never reached 160 degrees so in
some areas of that chamber
microorganisms
survived so now if the international
pharmacopeias require
proof of efficacy using accepted
designated heat resistant bacterial
spores
and you have to prove elimination of 1
million microorganisms
and also there's a requirement to
circulate that heated air using a fan
or a blower so in short these
manufacturers now according to the
pharmacopeias have to provide proof
of sterilization proof of the efficacy
of their design
so here's an example of something to
look for for sterilization proof
in this case this incubator
eliminates all of these microorganisms
tested including
the approved indicator for dry heat
sterilization bacillus atrophies or
bacillus suddenly
and also the approved indicator for
autoclave sterilization the geobacillus
and you can see the number of
microorganisms that were tested
clearly for those two last species
there's between a million and 10 million
tested uh you can see that no growth was
discovered and
this this the the log reduction here is
shown as well
in this case this test was done with a
45 minute cycle at 180 degrees
for a six log reduction and then that
treatment was doubled
using the u.s pharmacopoeia overkill
approach
so the cycle actually heats to 180
degrees for 90 minutes for an effective
12
log sterility assurance level
another thing to look for when
considering dry heat sterilization
is a temperature map so all areas of
that incubator actually reach and hold
at the specified temperature or the
specified
amount of time so in this case here's
one example of what to look for this is
a 48-point temperature map
showing that all areas reach at least
180 degrees for at least 90 minutes
that assures you that all areas truly do
reach that temperature
and there are no cold spots where
microorganisms could survive
okay two last things to talk about for a
contamination features
of of an incubator the first is
ultraviolet light
so ultraviolet light you're actually
hearing more about now with regard to
ways to control the sarskova ii
coronavirus
and ultraviolet light has long been used
in biological safety cabinets
um now there's the thing about uv light
is it requires a certain intensity
of the light for a certain time so it's
about time
and exposure okay so for example if i
just
walk from my office to my car i probably
won't get a sunburn
but if i sit outside in the sun for two
hours i probably will get a sunburn so
it's about the intensity
and the duration of exposure to the uv
light
so with this in mind some manufacturers
have started to offer uv light
to decontaminate the air in an incubator
and this seems like a great idea we use
it in the bsc
but it turns out that it's one of those
ideas that in practice doesn't work so
great
part of it is that an incubator has a
lot of parts that will block that uv
light and
areas in shadow are not disinfected
most importantly in the incubator
most incubators for cell culture have a
humidity level
of 80 to 95 percent so it's very humid
and that air is about five percent
water vapor and it turns out that that
water vapor
is reducing the effectiveness or
blocking the uv light in the incubator
so while uv light works nice in a
large uh empty biosafety cabinet
in an incubator with a bunch of parts
that can block the light and but most
importantly with that high humidity
it's just not very effective also the
bulb
effectiveness decreases with age as
those bulbs get older the light
intensity decreases so
it's important to know even in the bsc
how old is your uv light so that you
know when to change it so that it
actually will be effective
okay the last technology i'm going to
talk about is hydrogen peroxide vapor
so hydrogen peroxide is a really
effective broad spectrum disinfectant
and it's actually been tested and
approved by the u.s environmental aid
prac in u.s environmental protection
agency
as an approved disinfectant but only
a specific type of
of automated uh manual i'm sorry
machine produced hydrogen peroxide it
has to be 35 percent
it has to be performed by professionals
using a machine as pictured
here and what happens is the hydrogen
peroxide
liquid is vaporized it kills the
microorganisms on contact
now reputable company will test and show
the effectiveness they will show that no
microorganisms survived
and they will also guarantee that they
neutralize this toxic chemical which
otherwise can pose a risk
to lab workers for disinfecting a co2
incubator
there are some companies now that are
offering dry non-condensing hydrogen
peroxide and that's
the best approach because it's not going
to cause corrosion in the incubator
and affect the electronics
now someone said to themselves you know
hydrogen peroxide is a really effective
disinfectant let's
automate it in a co2 incubator and that
sounds like a great idea but it turns
out in practice it's hard to
really do effectively because when
you're
automating it it's really hard to
completely distribute those molecules
around
every area of the incubator and so any
areas that
don't make contact with that hydrogen
peroxide
droplets microorganisms can
survive also you have to take out all of
the parts of the incubator and
reposition them
so that it doesn't block spreading of
that vapor phase hydrogen peroxide
and then after the cycle is over you
have to pull out all of those parts and
put them back into place
again so it's actually a lot of work for
you
it doesn't save any time over just
you know manually cleaning and
disinfecting your incubator yourself and
autoclaving the parts
and then finally you see that there is a
puddle at the end of this
35 hydrogen peroxide which is really
toxic for
you and toxic for your cells so it's
again it's more
more work for you and it's a little bit
of danger for the user and then also you
have to continue to purchase that
specific
concentration of hydrogen peroxide and
the cost for that add up
so when you're looking at different
features for contamination control in a
co2 incubator
look for independent proof are the tests
to show the efficacy done by independent
test labs not by the manufacturer
what's involved in that process for you
does it actually require a lot of time
for the people in your lab to perform
that process
could you repeat the experiment when you
look at the marketing brochure are the
graphs clearly labeled are the axes
labeled do you know what they're
measuring or is it just kind of a pretty
dramatic graph and you don't exactly
know what it's
what it's telling you and if you look
for a table of microorganisms tested and
eliminated
is it just a list of zeros or do you
know how many microorganisms they
started with did they really start with
1 million
or did they only start with 50 for
example
and do all areas reach the specified
temperature
do you see a temperature map showing you
that everybody reaches those
every place in that incubator reaches
that specified temperature
okay so just finishing up with a few
words about thermoscientific incubators
because um you know they sent me here
so um thermoscientific incubator
thermoscientific has been making co2
incubators for more than 60 years
and many of the features available on
co2 incubators today were first
introduced by thermoscientific
so we actually have a few new models of
incubators that were introduced in the
last few years that have new
technologies
including redesigned airflow cutting
edge co2 sensors
covered water reservoir that also heats
and humidifies the gases
so better contributing to fast recovery
after a door opening
proven sterilization um options for
variable oxygen
oxygen control and all of these
technologies are have been tested by
third party test labs
finally i mentioned a quarantine
incubator early in the talk
one option for that is a new design from
thermoscientific
our cell locker system where a standard
incubator has been subdivided into these
six
polycarbonate boxes each of which holds
nine t75 flasks or up to 28 micro
uh microwell plates and it's filtered
air
so that no microorganisms could enter
and leave so if you're working with stem
cells or primary cells
and you want to protect those in a
shared incubator this is a good option
if your lab is starting to work on
testing coronaviruses
this is a good way to to isolate
different viral clones for example
okay i want to save a little bit of time
for questions so just to summarize
the take-home points here cell culture
contamination is a continuing challenge
for
everybody and it includes bacteria
including mycoplasma
fungi viruses but also
cross-contamination
from other cell lines and volatile
organic compounds
that also pose a risk to your cells we
all know that contamination takes a lot
of time and money can even
affect your reputation prevention of
contamination
requires doing all the things you know
you're supposed to do
including maintaining your good
technique
in the co2 incubator contamination in
any incubator comes from outside the
incubator
and there are good ways to prevent
contamination in the incubator
cleaning regularly or 100
copper or hepa filtration when you're
looking at these different methods
look at the data provided can you repeat
the experiment do you clearly understand
what they're showing
and ultraviolet light and automated
hydrogen peroxide are not really
effective solutions for controlling
contamination in the incubator and all
of this is important because everything
that you do
depends on your cells growing in a
healthy fashion
we do have a lot of technical resources
available at our website at
thermofisher.com
co2 and that's the end thanks everybody
for your attention
i guess i have some time to take a few
questions
and thank you mary kay for that
informative presentation
and we will start the live q a portion
of this webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time
for so let's take a look at our
questions already coming in
and what a great audience we have today
we already have so many questions
ready for you mary kay our first
question is
is biological containment popularly
used to mitigate the accidental release
of microorganisms that can infect
a human okay
so i'm not entirely sure what the
question is about biological containment
um so i think if we're talking about
biological containment
generally in the laboratory we're
talking about the bio safety cabinet
it's really important to
it's really important to use a biosafety
cabinet that's been properly balanced
and certified because
as those hepa filters load up
that can can that can affect how the air
flow
protects not only your cultured cells
but also
you as a laboratory worker if you're
especially if you're working with
human cells so um and and i guess
in the incubator another way to consider
biological containment is that cell
locker system i just talked about
thank you mary kay our next audience
member says
we're getting recurrent mold growth
in primary cell culture and we have also
been noticing
slow growth and growth in patches
can mold cause these growth issues
also or suggestions for eradicating
mold do you have any
well mold is always a tough one because
it circulates in the laboratory air
and primary cells are particularly
difficult because they're coming from
an animal or you know human cells and so
they're bringing their own normal flora
with them
so uh that might be a situation where
you want to use an anti-fungal in the
growth medium
and then also really really clean the
laboratory
and look at the ceiling air ducts in the
lab and see
is that blowing contaminated air around
the lab or onto the incubator
also think about where is the biosafety
cabinet positioned
is it in an area where you have a lot of
traffic walking back and forth in front
of the bsc because
that can affect how airflow enters the
bsc
um and so you might be having fun fungi
coming in
into the bsc with traffic and strange
airflow patterns inside the bsc so it's
better to put the bsd in a corner
rather than right next to a doorway for
example
and then the only other advice i have at
this
point is really clean the lab and try to
reduce the amount of circulating fungi
in the lab
and proper proper aseptic technique of
course um
if you want to send me an email we might
be able to talk more about this offline
thank you mary kay and in a multi-well
plate
should one discard all of the cells when
only one of the
wells is contaminated in a multi-well
plate
i would say yeah i would discard that
whole plate
theoretically they are all separated but
i
i'm guessing you started with the same
with the with the single culture
distributed across that plate so i would
discard that whole plate
thank you and again i want to thank our
audience members for these fantastic
questions coming in
our next question what is the best state
to leave an
empty co2 incubator between cultures
um could you repeat the question susie i
missed a word there what is the best
sure no problem what is the best feat or
way to leave an
empty co2 incubator between
cultures okay so
what's the best state to leave the co2
incubator okay um
so it depends on how long you're you're
leaving that co2 incubator if it's for a
week or more i would probably
clean it thoroughly and shut it down
turn off the co2 gas
empty out the water and that sort of
thing so for example if your lab has
shut down during the pandemic
you want to clean and disinfect it dry
it out
completely and turn off all of the
settings including the co2 gas
if it's a short term um i would still
so for example if you're between
projects and you're switching from
ending one project and starting another
one i would definitely clean and
disinfect
that incubator and start with clean
sterilized distilled water in the water
pan
thank you so much our next question
please let me know why most labs don't
prefer copy copper incubator and is
there any specific reason for that
i guess i would quibble with the idea
that most labs don't prefer
copper thermoscientific has been making
copper line incubators for more than 40
years and i
think we're up to 65 000
copper units produced over those years
so
a lot of people love copper but if i
were to give one reason why people would
prefer stainless steel i think it's
because you kind of get used to
stainless open the incubator and the
stainless steel is all shiny
and you feel like oh man that is really
clean
and then you if you look at a copper
incubator as i said it's
it's going to naturally develop
black and blue colors um and it just
doesn't look as clean so what i tell
people is close the incubator door you
shouldn't be using it as a mirror
that's where your cells are growing and
the copper is protecting your cells
but there are definitely some people who
are always going to prefer stainless
steel and that's okay too
thank you mary kay and thank you
audience members i just want to remind
everyone that any questions not asked
answered today will be answered via
email
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience
okay before we close
um i guess i would just say to everyone
stay safe
and best wishes for the safety of your
family and yourselves
and um good luck with your work um
and contamination is is something we all
battle with so
um just try and do all of the things
that your mom would tell you to do
in the laboratory
thank you again mary kay bates for this
great quest
presentation today i also want to thank
thermo fisher scientific for sponsoring
today's webinar i'd also like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
again
those submitted during on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
thank you everyone and have a great day
thank you susie